welcome to the planning committee of
Stratford District Council on 25th of
May 2023 my name is counselor Lewis Adam
I'll be chairing this evening
um just some housekeeping to begin with
if the fire alarm goes off it's not
planned so if you'll follow everybody
out to the car park beside the windmill
Pub and we'll check your names off the
attendance list there can everybody
please make sure their phones are off
released turned to silent so that they
don't disturb the flow of the meeting
uh this meeting is being recorded and
broadcast on the website it is a meeting
in public not a public meeting and so
only speakers who are registered to
speak are allowed to do so they'll be
called up at the correct time and
instructions giving her that point I'll
now introduce the top table to my left
I've got from democratic Services Kira
Keller uh our solicitor tonight is Amy
Shipley our planning manager on my right
is Richard Gardner and we have planning
officers Charlotte Dix Paul Thompson
Stuart McIver and Emma Booker I believe
Richard has a statement he'd like to
read out
uh thank you Mr chairman just to confirm
that my role tonight is to provide
impartial advice and to assist members
in their decision taking thank you
thank you very much okay so on to the
agenda uh first one is apologies for our
absence
of organ substitute and Pemberton
counselor score substitute
thank you very much so item number two
is disclosures of interest I'm going to
start and say that I have a disclosure
on item number five my wife is the
Parish Clerk for napton Parish Council
I've discussed this with a monitor
officer and he assures me that no
dispensations required I've also been
contacted by a representative of the
applicant on item number six and I
believe other people are on the
committee have as well yep so I think
that'll be a blanket
um disclosure for that one
are there any other disclosures
Council organ
respect item seven I'm an award member
and have come to this meeting with an
open mind so I will be taking part in
any deliberations thank you
thank you very much any other
declarations no okay well in that case
uh we need to look at the minutes from
the previous meetings held on the 5th
and 19th of April I take it everyone's
had a chance to read them and say is
there a accurate reflection
you know agreed
I'll sign those in due course okay on to
the agenda proper then item number four
is for application 22
fulberry Court Farm shot as well Banbury
and the presenting officer is Charlotte
Dix take it away Charlotte thank you
thank you chair
so the site is indicated on the map by
the black circle the application site is
located to the south of the village of
shotswell in the open Countryside
this slide shows the application site
edged in red it's an agricultural field
which is in the Einstein Hills special
landscape area the dotted green line to
the left hand side indicates the nearest
public right-of-way whilst the pink line
around the village of shot swell
indicates the conservation area the M40
is also visible on the right hand side
so this is a full application for a
change of use to allow secure dog
walking with infrequent use as an
agricultural grazing field
associate associated with the change of
use is in 1.8 meter high fence which is
proposed along the boundary of the six
meters away from the boundary of the
site with a field shelter close to the
access
one car parking space would be provided
on an area of existing hard standing
indicated by the triangle
at this point here
the existing dog walking field mentioned
within the report is visible within the
pink line to the right hand side of the
slide
so this slide shows the proposed fencing
which would be 1.8 meters high and made
out of wooden posts and high tensile
wire
this plan shows the proposed Timber
field shelter which would measure 2.1
meters in height and approximately three
square meters in area
so this photo shows the entrance into
the site where the gate and field
shelter would be cited
this photo is taken as you move further
into the site
the location is indicated by the map on
the right hand side with the Arrow
showing that the view is facing north
towards the existing area of Woodland
so this photo is taken panning around
now facing west as shown by the map
so this is towards the western boundary
of the site you can see the ground level
difference across the site as it rises
towards the western boundary
the trees and hedge in the background of
the photo denote the western boundary of
the site
so this photo is taken a panning round
in a similar location to the previous
one now looking towards the southern
boundary of the site the closest line of
trees and hedge that you can see denotes
the southern boundary of the site
this photo is taken from outside of the
site as indicated by the map and the
array looking back towards the site and
showing the existing vegetation along
the southern boundary
this photo shows part of the eastern
boundary where it meets the existing
particular track
the site is marked by the vegetation on
the left hand side of the photo with the
existing dog walking field sighted
beyond the Hedge on the right hand side
of the photo
this photo shows the existing hard
standing which would be used as the
single parking space with maneuvering
area for the use of the site
I've now got a video to show you the
site as well
so this starts facing towards the access
we're now panning around looking towards
the south of the site
sorry you can't see that bear with me
one moment
so this is taken as I mentioned so
facing towards the access we're now
panning round to the southern boundary
of the site with the vegetation showing
the boundary
so now panning round to the western
boundary
again with the vegetation the tree that
you can now see that indicates the
boundary of the site
again panning round now
towards the northern part of the site
and then the trees you can see there are
the the wooded area on the Northern
boundary and again back around to the
eastern part of the site now
and that's taken from almost the highest
point of the site
so just to clarify there are updates
within the update sheet officer
recommendation is to Grant the
application subject to completion of a
legal agreement and subject to the
suggested conditions and notes on pages
27 and 28 of the agenda including
amended condition five which is noted in
the update sheet thank you chair
thank you very much Charlotte so it's
now time to call our first Speaker who's
councilor Faulkner the chairman of
shotswell Parish Council counselor you
have three minutes I'll give you a 30
second warning and when you're ready
take it away
sorry counselor you just need to turn
your microphone on if you want to start
again
okay start again good evening the parish
council has been approached by a number
of residents expressing their concerns
about further traffic being generated
down this narrow bendy single track Lane
and also the noise from the dogs that
are already being exercised in the
current two dog fields this narrow road
so as far as five existing properties
along Church Lane and additionally the
Berry Court Farm Complex Berry Court
Farm originally farmed with two Farm
Workers Cottages expanded two further
cottages and latterly a further four
dwellings this coupled with the traffic
the shepherd's Hertz exists in two dog
Fields alongside the regular Farm
Vehicles surprise and logging business
has a high cumulative traffic flow which
is already causing significant issues
before this application was submitted
residents informed that they'd
complained to highways about the speed
of vehicles and the volume of traffic
many of which were mounting the verges
to pass in the process cutting up the
verges and dragonbra onto the road due
to safety concerns of their children
animals Redlands found further Lane has
erected his own size having one cat
killed on the road highlights in the
danger due to the ounce of the Road
Traffic calming is not possible and the
interest to our well-used children's
playing field is also on this Lane so
the dangerous children in particular
cannot be understated
the proposed additional field lies along
two feet alongside two fields which are
used to breeding area in sheep although
High fencing might be installed this
color prevented dogs from barking which
we for whatever The Possession the
potential to Spook the lifestyle and
cause distress
we feel another large field taken out of
food production is not good given the
need for food security we know the
caveat for occasion agriculture use this
is currently a good quality herbal field
the farm is already Diversified aside
from the items already mentioned the
farmer rents out burdens for garages and
other parts of the village so we are
trying not to prevent diversification
but we feel it must be appropriate and
proportionate to his environments
highways confirm this is a desk assessed
assessment without visiting you cannot
fully appreciate how much traffic is
used in the using or the condition of
the lane
people are traveling many miles come to
Charlottesville which is not good but
the district needs States the need for
travel should be reduced from the
support Commerce summer traveling as far
away as daventry and Beyond bypassing
closer fields to them indeed all the
supporting letters are coming from
people who are traveling to
Charlottesville by car to use the
facilities the village is simply not
equipped to cope with this much traffic
not all the traffic comes to be the via
the B4 100 million seconds many arrive
from Selden Road and end up getting lost
in fact people live in very Court Lane
further down the village have complained
that cars are turning around their
drives pictures show the issues
surrounding lorries trying to access
Church Lane we've also been aware that
despite the conditions of operation of
the existing field the hours of
operation are being exceeded
illustrating that conditions cannot be
enforced we have provided the lpo
Endeavors of this but we're not allowed
to show it on the screen we have deer in
the valley all of these high fences
prevented from roaming and can force
them onto them that's what I'm gonna
have to ask you to wrap it up there if
that's all right okay thank you very
much uh members do we have any questions
for the parish council
no okay well thank you very much for
your contribution uh can you just turn
the microphone off there please thank
you
okay so our next speaker is Mr Tom pick
who is the applicant
uh Mr pick you also have three minutes
I'll give you a 30 second warning
and when you're ready take it away
hey everyone I'm Tom pick the owner of
shotswell secure dog walking fields and
the applicant for this third field
so your dog walking field provides an
important service to the members of the
public with dogs who aren't if you don't
have access to suitable areas to safely
walk their dogs I have two existing
secure fields which opened in May last
year and the popularity has exceeded my
expectations and the demand has been
hard unanticipated I'm proposing to open
a third field to help keep up with the
demand
as of this morning the next available
slot in my large field is the 3rd of
July if you wanted to come on a weekday
or the 20th of August if you wanted to
come over the weekend this along with my
1200 members proved just how popular
these fields have become and there is
clearly a demand for them I believe I'm
providing an important service to the
local community
the proposed new Fields will be book all
in one hour slots with 15-minute
changeover periods between bookings this
ensures there are no overlapping visits
and gives clients time to leave the
village before the next client arrives
I appreciate the parish council's
concerns about increasing traffic and
loss of Farmland however I have a
business to run and livelihood to make
the loss of the single Farm payment has
compounded the need to diversify and
come up with alternative income streams
and uses for land especially the less
productive land like this field in
question
with the field been open from 7am to 7
30 PM this equates to 10 bookings per
day and therefore 10 cars a day because
each booking is limited to one car per
booking
when clients make a booking they get
emailed at a very specific set of
instructions on how to get to the fields
from the main road to cause minimal
disruptions to the within the village
I would also like to say we aren't
losing agricultural lands like you would
if you built houses on the land this is
simply taking it out of production in
the future this land could be reverted
back to arable production
if planning is granted I'm also planning
on using sheep to graze the field
occasionally or cut the grass to make
hay to feed the cows over winter if it
gets too long
last year we produced over 2 000 tons of
crops and of that 43 tons came from this
field which I'm proposing to convert to
dog walking Fields this equates to only
two percent of the Farm's total
production
taking this land out of our production
was also have the benefits of reducing
the number of 44 ton Arctic lorries that
need to drive through the village to
collect the grain we produce
thank you for your time and I welcome
any questions you have
thank you very much well within your
time members do we have any questions
for our applicant
no oh
counselor Keeley councilor Keithley yeah
I'd just like to ask for a bit of
clarification on the comments about the
vehicles having to pass because it's not
clear to me
how the hgvs and the cars are passing
each other on this narrow track could
you help me with that please
so
um they won't be able to pass on the
tracks they're now roads we don't get
that many hdvs a year maybe 50 to 60 so
the chance of them meeting a car are
pretty slim
um and if they if they do happen to meet
them the car just has to reverse back
down to the farm or pull into a lay-by
or something along along the road it
depends where they meet them depending
on the outcome
could I just carry on with another line
of questioning on on you mentioned
pulling into a lay-by if if a car does
meet an hgv yeah what are the
arrangements then your car has to
reverse back how far does it need to
reverse Bank
um at the most at the most
if the law is not prepared to move I'd
say 100 meters
fighting distance for the cast to see
the lorries coming so they can see just
as a straight track isn't it
the worst bit is as you're coming
directly into the farm or leaving the
farm as a slight there's a left-hand
turn coming in which is about 100 meters
before you get to the farm entrance
and so that's the worst case scenario
and if the car happened to meet them
there
thank you uh councilor pertigella
yeah thank you um so you have already
two audio sent dog walking fields
and so the the with the booking system
for this field for this proposed field
um take into consideration any vehicle
movement generated by your other
adiascent dog walking fields
they'd be run in parallel to each other
so at any one time there can be three
cars because I've got if if this is
granted I'd have three Fields so there'd
be three cars per hour
coming in and out
are there any more questions from
Members no in which case thank you very
much thank you
nice uh award member is not registered
to speak so we'll now move on to uh
questions of clarification from the
officers uh members do we have any
questions of clarification
hesitant
possibly one from counselor Keithley
I do and it's it's really about the the
highways and the traffic issues on to
get access to this site along this Lane
um
so there's no overlapping visits I read
and if I've read correctly you'll report
states that
um
even with the addition of this field and
the existing two fields
um it's not envisaged you say that this
will lead to a significant
intensification of use of the current
access point with the highway
can you just
help me understand how you arrived at
that
conclusion about the intensification of
traffic
please
um so the intensification but when we
assess an application we would obviously
take advice from County highways we have
no objection in place in terms of the
use of the access from the highway for
the additional vehicle that would be
coming to the site for every booking
and in terms of intensity we would look
at the existing use so as an
agricultural use we would obviously
expect some level of vehicle movements
from and to the site
and looking at the wider site as well in
terms of looking at the existing dog
walking fields and the sync the single
cars that they would have for each of
those fields so the assessment was that
one additional car per booking was not
considered as significant increase from
the existing situation so as to cause
detrimental impacts of the highway
safety
hmm
thank you for that and I've got a
further question if that's okay
um I've read that there's some concern
about the potential for the dogs to
disturb livestock
so could you just help me understand
where the fence is going to be
positioned in relation to the boundary
of the field and whether or not there's
a margin between the fence and the field
boundary and the potential well let's
say the boundary between the field the
fence for the dogs and the field in
which the livestock might be does that
make sense because I'd like to just get
a feel for whether or not
um the
objections around
dogs disturbing livestock is is is a
potential issue and I want to understand
that because this looks from your video
to be a very very large field
so in terms of that assessment
um there is a secure dog fence proposed
around the entire site so this would be
inside of the existing vegetation that
you saw from the photos and it's
approximately six meters away from the
about the existing boundary
one of the conditions is in terms of the
sighting of that fence so we would have
control in terms of where that's located
um but in addition to that there is an
exist there's existing vegetation around
the site as well so in terms of um and
there's also a landscaping condition
proposed as well in terms of soft
Landscaping so we can in terms of
officers consideration we don't consider
there to be a significant harm to
livestock because of those precautions
that would be put into place also noting
the fact that there's an existing
right-of-way in quite close proximity on
the other side of the field that we're
talking about
um so there's obviously a potential for
for dogs to be walking along that
right-of-way
um
but in terms of officers assessment we
don't consider the risks to livestock to
be to be significant
okay Alex thank you very much for that
clarification
counselor de Gallup
so there is a planning there
is site so I think Port you said there's
going to be
confirmed that no Shepherds up will be
put to there by so106 agreement could
you tell us why you're going down the
legal route and what happens to that
planning application thank you
yes of course so there is an extent
permission for a shepherd's hat within
the field itself so it would be located
approximately in this area here if you
can see where the cursor is
um that hasn't been put into place so
the other Shepherd's hats are already on
site but the applicants will not be
putting that Shepherd's Hut into place
on this site the section 106 agreement
has been proposed to try and um
ensure that the land use would be
compatible with the other lung users are
proposed so in terms of the immunity for
any occupies of that Shepherd's hurt
we've assessed that this legal agreement
would be required to make sure that the
immunity is acceptable for for both of
those uses so we would be looking to get
a legal agreement secured to make sure
that the shepherd's hurt
that has been approved within this field
could not be implemented and the
applicant has agreed to
um to not Implement that part of the
permission
councilor Adam
thank you
um just a quick question on the other
two sites are they anywhere
directly adjacent to or nearby because
the parish council talked about
cumulative noise
that's the first question and then the
second sort of linked question is if
they are nearby
is the fencing that's being proposed in
keeping with those other two sites
sorry yes of course so one of the
existing fields that is used for secure
dog walking is this field on the right
hand side which is indicated by the pink
line
if you bear with me I can also show you
where the other is located as well
so this was the red line plan submitted
for the application for the existing dog
walking obscure facility so this is the
field that I've just referred to and
this is where the other field is located
so it's closer to the Berry Court farm
buildings themselves and you will see
that this is the application site here
on the left hand side at the bottom of
the screen
um so in terms of cumulative noise
environmental health had no objections
in terms of noise in that regard
and in terms of the fencing the fencing
that is proposed is the same as the
fencing that's already in place for the
existing site
councilor pattingham
right condition number 10 is planting of
grass outside the the perimeter for um
for encouragement of skylarks which is
very commendable good sort of suggestion
but it seems to me with the with the
Woodland that's in there and the hedges
around there'd be a lot more potential
for other ecological and Wildlife
enhancements is that something that the
was considered in terms of the
conditions
so in terms of the impact on the natural
college natural environments
um yes so in terms of the assessment
that the county colleges has made the
sky the condition regarding the skylarks
is um just in terms of the timing for
the introduction of grass onto the site
just to make sure that that doesn't
impact on any skylarks that could be
using the field
in terms of any other
um
suggestions there's not anything that
the county ecologist considered would be
reasonable in terms of the scale of the
development
oh right
any more points clarification
if not then we can move on to the debate
who would like to start
Elsa Eden
thank you chair
um okay so I think for me
what's being proposed is in keeping I
understand the concerns about the
additional noise I also understand
to a degree the intensification of
traffic however highways are saying
that's not a problem
[Music]
um
I think to my mind
um I'm feeling that I'd probably sway
towards going with officers
recommendations to be honest but I won't
propose just yet oh let's let's see what
everybody else says
thank you Carlson uh councilor Fleming
um yeah I I don't see any huge issue
with this it's not like he's signing it
away for 40 years for a solar farm this
is something that could be rescinded or
reused within Agriculture and it's not
going to affect an awful lot of people
the point about it is that I mean I see
in the additional notes that people have
to use cars to get there well
if people can afford to walk that people
have got fit enough to walk that far
they don't really need a dog walking
field so there's always going to be cars
because there are isolated areas so from
my perspective and what I've seen in the
notes ready in the notes heard about the
um defensing being a certain distance
back so it's not going to trouble as a
livestock
um I'm looking to be supporting the
officer's recommendation
thank you Council firming is that a
proposal
yes it is a proposal yeah
Carl's Redden
uh if no one else wants to speak on it
I'll second that
jolly good we've got a proposal and a
secondary is anyone else looking to
speak on this item
sounds like Italy
um what I'd like to say is that I can
see uh the need for this type of
facility if more and more people are
having dogs are needing to train them so
I think that there's an economic
potential economic benefit in a rural
environment and having got some
clarification I'm not persuaded that the
objection is relating to the
intensification of traffic and vehicles
and the harm to livestock I'm not
persuaded that those are really
significant objections
that's my comment
thank you very much anyone else to want
to contribute I'll just add in my bit um
essentially I think I agree with uh with
what's been said I can understand why
there are uh concerns but they seem to
have been addressed and from planning
point of view I don't think there's
anything substantial to go against
um so I think in that case we'll be
looking to go through a vote
uh the proposal is to Grant and
I'm ready to read out the name
so the proposal is to Grant
um the application 22
02574 S View L Berry Court Farm
shotswell all those in favor
yeah sure um just just for clarity sorry
um that's on the uh based on the
conditions um that have been stated in
the report and including the note uh
regarding the legal agreement which I
believe was
understood by the proposal and secular
uh failing that all those in favor
I believe that's unanimous
in which case this committee has
moved to Grant application Twitter two
zero two five seven four slash fulberry
Court Farm shotswell
okay moving on to item number five then
it is application
fully in Folly Lane napton on the hill
our presenting officer is Paul Thompson
and once he's had a seat and you can
take it away
bear with me
got there in the end
thank you chair good evening councilors
ladies and gentlemen in the gallery uh
we are here in napton in on the hill in
the east of the district uh the subject
of the application is the Folly in
um it's by the Oxford Canal it's at the
foot of napton Hill
and as we can see here there are a
number of public rights of way going
past it the those are the green dashed
lines the red buildings are listed all
at grade two they include the Folly
itself uh which is a public house they
this building here is the Canal Bridge
it's Bridge 113 over the Oxford canal
and this group of buildings here is lock
Cottage and uh the lock itself and a
couple of other
Associated buildings
um
this is a retrospective application
which is to say that the building for
which permission is sought has already
been erected it is in use
it is this
structure here
between the canal the pub and the canal
it looks rather like this it's a Timber
structure with a corrugated steel roof
the roof as you'll see presently is is
gray rather than green but it's a very
fairly simple shed like structure set
slightly lower than
Folly Lane um this is this this picture
was taken in March this year
um the folly in the list of building is
over there on the left of the frame and
the building in question occupies the
rest of the frame
and this is looking from the same
location towards the Canal Bridge and
you can just see that the distance
between the Canal Bridge which is
essentially the first point at which you
see the pub
um and the building there
uh share the recommendation is to refuse
planning permission
um on the grounds of
harm to the list of building and harm to
local character and distinctiveness
uh
there is an update on the update sheet
before I forget clearly the reason we
are here is because the parish council
supports the application rather than
because they're objecting
um that is on the update sheet for the
sake of clarity chair thank you
thank you very much Paul okay so our
first speaker is uh councilor Richard
Woodcock the chairman of maplin Parish
Council
Richard you have
three minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning and when you're ready
okay and just to remember to switch on
the microphone
this is rare for napton Parish Council
to support a retrospective planning
application however that in itself
should alert this committee to the vital
importance of our support to this
application of the Folly Public House
the building in question was constructed
in haste to mitigate the devastating
consequences of the main Pub being
unsuitable for social distancing during
the restricted covid-19 pandemic period
the government is recommended to
planning authorities that they should
show lenience to support Hospitality
trade at a time of Crisis and it would
be true to say that this building has
saved our Pub
s are closing Nationwide and we've
already lost three of five pubs in our
village the pub trade is yet to recover
full Revenue since the pandemic and The
Current financial crisis means that this
building continues a continued use is
vital to the Pub's Financial viability
the additional space provides a unique
Community Asset for a dementia Club a
ukulele Club a live and local talent
Night Live music groups and musicians as
well as a popular eating area and
meeting place for local families
meanwhile the pub in its entirety
supports tourism throughout the catering
and Canal boat trade which spills over
supporting local businesses through
Community employment opportunities and
is a clear benefit to the local
community
the planning officers have already
confirmed in the report in front of you
that this building is fully compliant in
their considerations of residential
immunity highways access and parking
infrastructure water environment and
flood risk natural environment and
climate change the planning inspectorate
has also confirmed that there is no
significant impact on the Ironstone Hill
SLA as per policy cs-12 of the core
strategy
policy cs22 also confirms support to
this type of development and that the
exam expansion is acceptable in
principle
Stratford District Council planning have
further determined that the building
causes less than substantial harm to the
local character in the immediate
vicinity including the listed buildings
policy CS 8 of the core strategy
specifically states that where a
development leads to less than
substantial harm to the Heritage asset
this can be outweighed by the public
benefits of The Proposal
the photos which you can see show that
the visual impact of this development
from both the Canal Bridge and the
Towpath are minimal
our case is an Upton Parish Council
representing the local community is that
the public benefit greatly exceeds any
perceived harm caused by this building
this is our neighborhood development
plan that is now being quoted by
Stratford District Council planners to
try to justify their own conclusions for
refusal yet there is not one single
objection to this building from a local
community of a Thousand Villages North
and the many Canal boats which Maura put
the Folly each day
the fullest contribution to the local
community is even highlighted in our
Upton neighborhood development plan
policy 12.
so surely this is a case where localism
supports common sense and we implore you
to pass the application tonight for this
vital Community Asset thank you thank
you very much councilor Woodcock do we
have any questions from our members
councilor Fleming
did you say there's been no objections
to this at all not a single objection
and you're supporting the pro the
project we fully support the project yes
okay and uh you see you were saying this
is a Community Asset is this one of
these situations where the pub dies the
village died the freaks are really it's
in no Center for a community Spirit then
really well it's it's certainly the a
very important Community Asset I
wouldn't say there's no other facility
but it is a very important one and it's
one of only two pubs left out of five
and we fear that we could lose it if we
lose this building
any more questions from members
councilor Keithley uh yeah I just wanted
to understand a little better the the
argument that is it this the significant
public benefit would outweigh the harm
of the setting of the listed building so
it was really a question about what
happened before this building went up
and before covid struck and where was
live music and what was happening
to the community Spirit at that time Mr
Village Hall or Community Hall or
something else in your there isn't there
is a village hall in the village so some
of the events could have taken place
there but the reality is that this Pub
has generated a community spirit and
this particular building has expanded on
that Community Spirit we never had a
dementia club before we never had live
and local before and all the other sorts
of things that that I've listed so it's
enhanced The Village it's very popular
with the village and as I've already
stated not a single member of our
community sees any problem with it
whatsoever
sorry
oh is that okay sorry
um
you mentioned that the canal boat trade
was important as well
can you give us a feel for
uh the sort of makeup of the trade that
uses this facility is it mostly people
coming through or traveling to the
village is it and how big is the
community how many people live in the
village
there's a thousand people live in the
village in 600 houses and then you get a
daily flow of canal boats through the
through the the canal napton's a very
important part of the canal structure
and our village survives off the canal
really and the Folly public course is
right next to it so typically
um the road from the Folly which is a
dead end runs straight into the village
and takes people to the Village shop for
example it also takes them to the church
it also takes them to the garage in the
village so people on the canal are
actually using our village facilities
and the pub sort of encourages them to
stop rather than go past and then you
also get the local villagers which value
this Pub greatly and then in addition to
that its reputation is such that you've
got things like the dementia group the
ukulele group the live and local and
live music so it's bringing in people
from the outside area which again are
using other facilities in the village so
it's absolutely vital to our tourist
trade and of course our employment
are there any other questions
no okay Council thank you very much for
your contribution
okay so the next speaker we have is uh
Simon robbery who is the agent for the
application I believe
Mr robbery you have three minutes I'll
give you a 30 second warning when you're
ready to take it away
thank you chair um good evening I'm
Simon robbery I'm a child of town
planner my clients forget the situation
that they're in the original agent was
not a town planner and they were wrongly
advised about the need for planning
permission the first application and
appeal were poor no supporting evidence
about the public benefits also it did
not clearly state that the application
was for a temporary period of three
years and I don't think Paul mentioned
that we're seeking a temporary consent
here this application's fully supported
with the necessary information including
a Heritage assessment and an analysis of
public benefits we fully support the
parish's comments the officers assess
less than substantial harm and paragraph
tour to the mppf requires that in such
cases the harm should be weighed against
the public benefits of The Proposal
including where appropriate securing is
Optimum viable use
we submitted a detailed catalog of the
public benefits including jobs
contribution to local tourism its
function as a de facto Community Center
and its contribution to the local rural
economy the officer report only briefly
recognizes these it doesn't properly
undertake the balancing exercise
mentioned above merely concludes there's
insufficient evidence that the pub will
be unviable without any further analysis
the reports therefore flawed through not
properly undertaking the required
balancing exercise in accordance with
national policy consensus thought is
sought for three years however the
report appears to assess it as a
permanent structure in terms of its
Heritage impact it is not built as a
permanent structure it has no toilets it
is not anchored to the ground it's
merely resting on breeze blocks
to reassure Committee of our intentions
in the event that the consent for three
years is granted we are prepared to
commit to enter into pre-application
discussions within two years in respect
of how we may achieve an acceptable
permanent structure somewhere on the
site the temporary use will enable the
pub to continue to operate during
extremely challenging economic
conditions continuing covid recovery and
it is a continuing covert recovery
electricity price Rises raw product
price Rises including drinking food and
also significant core inflation which we
heard about yesterday which is reducing
disposable incomes without this
permission the role of the pub and its
attractiveness will be significantly
reduced the likelihood of the pub
remaining able to Triple seconds will be
limited with a real risk that a can
outside Pub a local community venue a
live music center and a rural community
and economic asset will be lost we're
simply seeking a three-year consent to
get us through the most challenging
economic period in living memory no
permanent harm is caused to any Heritage
asset
thank you chairman
thank you very much just within time
members do we have any questions for our
agent
Council Keithley thank you chair
um
yes I'm obviously very interested in in
your your background and thank you for
some of the points of clarification
reading the report the conservation
office have found that the design scale
and sighting of the building competes
with and distracted tracks from the
historic complex and Landscape that's
what's reported and you've just said
that you'd be happy to enter into a
legal agreement
to bring forward an acceptable permanent
structure so what I'm really quite
interested to know is what might an
acceptable permanent structure look like
on this site
so I'm afraid we have to keep this
within terms of the application in front
of us and we we can't all consider what
future applications may may envisage for
the site
um I'm afraid we have to keep that
grounded in this right if you'd like to
rephrase your question to sort of get
the information thank you
um okay so um I'm not sure I can
rephrase it because I'm interested in
what that might look like so what you're
really saying is it's a an application
for a three-year temporary structure
with a commitment to come forward with
something else at the end of that period
yeah
thank you Jeff
thank you very much any more questions
yes Council of Fleming
yeah it's quite obviously from its
appearance that it's a temporary
structure and it's not fixed to the
ground
um
obviously from covid you had to
have social distancing and that's that
was the reason for its constructs
correct yes
you say the pub may not survive very
well without this so councilor Fleming
do you mind just moving closer to your
microphone all right thank you
right okay
um yeah yeah so
the pub would be struggling without this
building
and uh whilst we know we can't talk
about what's going to be there in the
future
we really need to preserve
you know rural pubs are in in big
trouble
and uh so from from what I can see
um you're really just trying to preserve
the asset for a short period of time
until you get it right is that what
you're saying yeah okay that's all I
want to know
of the trade is
um
from the
building we're seeking consent from
if you look at the wet side it's about
60 so it is critical
thank you very much are there any more
questions no okay uh thank you very much
then Mr robbery
okay so we don't have the ward members
down to speak on this application which
means we're moving on to points of
clarification from our officers do we
have any points of clarification
thank you chair
um yeah I'd like to
um ask uh the officer to help us
understand
this sort of balance between the
um the design and the harm that's
brought to the location
and the balance of that against the
public benefits of the proposal and what
evidence was provided to you
um to uh to assess those public benefits
so that you could try and weigh that
balance up
uh you will have seen the evidence that
we have it's it's the evidence is
publicly available
um what we haven't seen I think is
perhaps
easier to explain and that's
um any detailed uh financial information
for example which wouldn't wouldn't be
publicized but would help us to have a
much clearer picture of the viability of
the pub which which in which case it
might be that the the assessment were
different we but we haven't received
that so what we've received is what
you've seen and what you've heard this
evening
um that's what we've come to
our assessment on
uh councilor put together
so yes we heard from the applicant that
they might be
um they could get into negotiation on
how a permanent structure will unlock I
mean is that something that can be
conditioned
not conditioned but it might be a
material consideration if we were to
receive an application in three years
time for the same building
um so in other words if
this temporary structure is just
intended to get the pub through a rough
patch and then we look at a permanent
structure next time well I think
zitastic acknowledgment by all parties
that that structure would need to be
better located
and better constructed
um so that would be something we would
we would better in mind it wouldn't we
it wouldn't be possible to draft a
condition requiring the applicant to
submit a particular application or to do
a certain thing like that
um to answer your question
uh Council Adam
just a quick one
um just for my own understanding so
because obviously the building is
already in existence this permission is
three years from
now not three years from when it was
erected
yes
yes okay uh Council Keith again yeah and
just follow up on a point clarification
and so a three-year temporary permission
would mean at the end of those three
years
what are the options
well the usual wording of the condition
in such circumstances is that
um on a certain date which in this case
would be three years from the date of
the planning permission
um the building must be demolished all
materials removed from the site or
recycled and the site restored to its
preceding state
any more questions of clarification
no in which case we can move on to the
debate who would like to start
castle of Fleming
um
for for the debate as far as I'm
concerned it's it's purely the balance
between harm
and and what it is
um so you know
from my perspective I think that the
benefits both to the total Community to
the building itself and the passing
trade from the um
from the canal and whatever else
on a personal level I think it outweighs
the harm that that building which has
been there for some time is actually
doing at this particular moment and
whether it would cause any further
distress or harm to anyone else for it
to remain for a minute for a period of
three years now I know if we overturn
stuff we've got to have really good
reasons to do so and what I'd like to
ask is is this does it carry sufficient
weight by
um
by the damage to the community versus
the damage to the damage of harm by the
building being there
um yeah that's the that's the that's
exactly the right balance is what you've
described there you've identified the
harm that this building causes two
listed buildings and Heritage assets but
you've also identified benefits
um to the community
um and you're entitled to outweigh one
with the other
um and you're also entitled to take into
account the fact that it's a three-year
permission and that would limit the
level of harm
um so there's been no objections to this
all we're getting is support from the
local Parish bought from the locals so
um as there's been no objections does
that carry any weight as well
um
there have been objections there's been
objection from the conservation officer
and there's also the material
consideration of what the inspector said
to take into account so those are those
are factors you'll need to weigh in the
balance
uh counselor organ
thank you chairman
um I have a deal of empathy towards this
application
this tempering application it has to be
said
in order to retain a local business that
does seem to be of great value to the
community
and it provides local employment
and it provides Community facilities
so I have some empathy towards actually
um not refusing this thank you
thank you very much I believe councilor
Eden next
thank you chair uh yeah pretty much
echoing councilor Fleming in organ with
their sentiments uh
the public benefit for me clearly
outweighs
um
the the harm especially that of a
temporary
um
permission
I think that's backed up on our own
policies with cs22 and cs25 could be
leaned on a little bit there to to
assist
um I will propose that we go against
officers recommendation and Grant on
that basis
okay thank you very much councilor Eden
councilor but together
um I mean the Army's less than
substantial and we know it's a temporary
structures which we condition a touch
but also our core strategy and I was
thinking about yes 22
um Economic Development states that the
planning process so should also support
the sustainability of a rural economy
so I think in that case I would uh you
know I would support these and also cs25
because it's the well-being and healthy
communities which I think this temporary
structure provides to the good people of
Neptune and so yes I'll I'll very much
in agreement with what has been said and
with counselor Ed and proposal
thank you very much Cox put together uh
councilor Keithley
um yeah I'd just like to add that um
I can see the support that the temporary
permission has from the local community
and whilst a recommendation is for this
to be refused on the balance
of the evidence that's been provided in
the application I think that I can see
um
benefits in in the rural economy to to
allow this through well what I would say
is that I do feel that the you know when
when applications come before the
officers they have to make a judgment
based upon the evidence that's provided
and
although I'm more convinced now
listening to the parish council and and
others talking
um perhaps when the application was
first brought forward the the the lack
of evidence of the public benefit
um
made it more difficult for the officers
to consider the application is what I
would like to say
thank you very much are there any other
contributions to the debate
so we have a proposal
yeah I have a proposal uh to go against
the officer's recommendation uh Richard
do we have all the reasons uh you need
to justify that
um yes we've got several what what I I'm
just need to be clear on because it may
become important in three years time is
to understand where the members feel
that there is harm to the Heritage
assets but that that's tempered by the
fact that it would only be for three
years and by the fact that you've heard
the agent today say they will make
efforts to re-plan the site in three
years time and I'm just trying to
understand the weight that members are
giving that point
I'm seeing not so I can see that you've
taken that into account but you're
outweighing that with
um the notes I've got here
as I've just said the temporary nature
of the structure
the fact that the businesses of value to
the local community and the fact that it
provides local employment within the
rural economy and it's those factors
that are outweighing that harm you've
identified albeit that harm is of three
years
okay lovely
okay thank you very much
um
yeah I was going to say if if we're
looking at going against officers
recommendation for a grant uh what
conditions can we apply to such a result
uh the chair if I may suggest uh we have
five approved plans standard condition
um
secondly that the roof be treated in
some way powder coated or painted to
make it a dark green or gray and to help
it sit within the landscape and that
would be
subjected details and the time scale for
completion to be submitted within three
months of mission being granted
uh drainage works are detailed in the
plans it wasn't immediately clear
whether they'd been implemented or not
so just a belt and braces condition to
ensure that they they have been
uh standard condition to ensure that the
building remains ancillary to the pub
um that it can't be sort of sold all
that separately
and finally the condition that I
explained to you counselor about uh just
in basically making it a temporary
permission how the building would be
removed at the end of three years after
the permission is granted and the site
restored to its former state
thank you very much um
okay
um I think everything's been said that
needs to be for this application there
seems to be
um a movement towards it so uh we've got
a proposal to Grant the application uh
for the Folly in Folly Lane Neptune on
the hill
uh can I see
subject to the conditions and the
wording to be delegated to the officers
thank you very much
we're getting there
can I see those all in favor please
that's unanimous
then this committee
um
sees to Grant application
230084 slash ful the Folly in Folly Lane
napton on the hill
right
um
we'll just wait for our uh next officer
to move in and we'll move on to item
number six
which is for applications 22
01485 ful and application
22-01486 ful Land north of Oakham Road
Southwest of long Compton are presenting
officer is Stuart McIver
um when you're ready you can take it
away
thank you chairman uh good evening
everyone
uh so the application site is
at land north of Oakham Road Long
Compton uh just to make things clear
I'll be doing one presentation but for
two applications at the site
uh one application is for the erection
of agricultural grain store with hard
standing access and associative works
and the other application is for the
erection of agricultural straw Barn
Again with hard standing access and
Associated works
uh you can see the application site
outlined in red here
so it's encompassed by a field
you can see the proposed access runs
adjacent to the field here
and you've got a couple of footpaths
which run in close proximity to the
application site
there we go sorry apologies uh so we've
got a slightly
um smaller scale
um location plan so the location uh the
application site is denoted by the black
dot uh approximately 800 meters
Southwest of the settlement of long
Compton
and then we go on to a proposed site
plan so you've got the two buildings
here which are side in close proximity
to each other
and then you can see that the buildings
are going to be cited very to the sort
of Northern extreme of the field and
that is
bounded by a mature Hedgerow with
um trees and various other vegetation
and then we just go on to
um some plans of the proposed grain
store so it's a very traditional uh sort
of agricultural building sort of dual
pitched form
uh you've got it's going to be clad in
dark stained vertical Timber cladding
with a corrugated metal roof with a
non-reflective finish
and then we just again go on to some
plans of the proposed straw bar again
very sort of traditional agricultural
building uh dual pitch Reef again darts
stained vertical Timber cladding uh
corrugated metal roof with a
non-reflective finish
and then we just go on to some site
photos from the application site
so this site photo is taken from the
entrance to the field
um just the open road hopefully you can
sort um face into towards the North to
the application site hopefully that's
quite clear with the map and the arrow
you can see that the land slows down to
the Northeast
um just uh
gently down towards the North East
and then we just move on to another site
photo so this is taken from the uh where
the access vehicular access is going to
be on the western edge of the
application site again looking sort of
North East towards where the buildings
are sighted you can kind of just see
here that there's a Hedgerow which is
visible and that's kind of denoted by
this line
on the location plan to the right there
so that's to the south of where the
buildings would be cited
and then we just moved on to another
site photo so this is now taken uh
directly adjacent to where the buildings
would be cited looking to the West
um hopefully it gives a sort of scale
this is the kind of Northern boundary of
the application site and of the field
and that kind of gives you a bit of
context in terms of the scale of that
vegetation there
and then finally we move on to another
cited photo so this is taken from a site
from public footpath to the north of the
application site but looking South and
you can kind of see that the land kind
of steeply drops off here heading
towards the North and you can kind of
see there you can just kind of get a
glimpse of the um vegetation that again
will be a screen in the buildings
um so in summary
um it's considered that the proposed
buildings are required to meet the
agricultural need created by the
expansion of arable land at Ashby farm
and whilst the proposed buildings will
be visible from some views from the
adjacent paths and Glimpse intermittent
longer distance views from the wider
landscape overall the effect on the
landscape would be limited and not
significant as such the proposed
development is considered comply with
the relevant provisions and a core
strategy and is recommended for approval
uh please see the update sheet for
updates thank you chairman
thank you very much uh so we have our
first speaker is Stuart Bing of long
Compton Parish Council
hello Miss Bing um you have three
minutes I'll give you a 30 second
warning
um
oh sorry yes yeah
when you're ready uh there should be
some photographs that should be coming
on uh on this Loop
before just before I start
foreign
I believe that's they'll be rolling
through so if you'd like to yeah let's
start when ready
foreign
good evening
um the proposed site sits in the
Cotswold natural landscape on the ridge
line above the village of long Compton
and as I'm sure all of you who have
visited this site prior to this evening
will have seen it's quite clearly
visible from all approaches as set from
the applicant's own land
Ashby Farm has been farmed by various
Farmers on a contract farming basis over
the years and we understand still
continues to be so for the applicant all
of the farmers to our knowledge have
used the buildings in situ at Cleve Farm
or elsewhere over the years without the
need for development on the site should
it be deemed necessary for buildings to
be erected on this part of the
applicants land the current proposed
site is wholly unacceptable and
inappropriate
there is a far more obvious and
unobtrusive site nearly 100 meters from
the highway entrance which is only
visible from the adjacent bride away
public Highway and the applicant's own
land as opposed to the whole of the
village in surrounding panorama
the buildings as you can see from the
photographs will be clearly visible from
nearly all aspects of the village and
surrounding area including the English
heritage site at the roll right Stones
the buildings will be significant in
their prominence in the landscape being
on the Ridgeline and this is going
against policy one of the long content
neighborhood development plan the lvia
sets out that the existing hedge line
and mature trees will shield the site
from view but as we all know trees are
only in leaf for a proportion of the
year and so in the autumn and winter
months this shielding will not be
present also it should be noted that a
high proportion of the vegetation is Ash
which is known to be prone to the
disease Ash dieback which has already
been noted in the surrounding area
including on the adjacent Farmland this
will inevitably mean that the trees will
have to be filled thus removing the
natural screening and making the
buildings even more prominent in the
skyline
the applicant's need for the ability to
store three crops due to
agri-environment schemes is no longer
relevant due to the relaxation of the
rules around Greening and no longer
having to grow multiple crops for BPS
purposes
in my professional experience a straw
Barn that is erected for the intention
of keeping straw hay and Machinery is an
open-fronted barn with cladding on three
sides in a hardcore base why would it be
necessary and reasonable for it to be
fully cladded and have a roller shutter
door this not only makes loading and
unloading of the barn inefficient and
impractical it surely adds expense which
the applicant has stated they are trying
to avoid
the design of This Barn is not in
keeping with the use intended the
proposed site is nearly a kilometer from
the entrance to the applicant's land why
would it be reasonably necessary to
build these buildings so far from the
highway the applicant is worried about
the economic cost of putting two
applications in for the buildings but
not about the potential costs building
an extra 800 meters at the track to the
site
there is a present no hard track to the
site capable of taking hgv's traffic
if as per the applicant statement in the
site will only be accessed by file
Machinery then surely vehicle movements
will remain the same as the need to cart
the grain by tractor will still exist
as a farm manager of over 5000 acres in
my professional opinion I cannot see how
this application in its current form
will benefit the applicant more than if
the buildings were sighted in close
proximity to the highway on their land
and I respectfully ask that the
application be refused I'm more than
happy to answer any questions the
committee may have especially in
relation to the agricultural need I'm
afraid you have to wrap it up right
there
thank you
uh thank you councilor Bing um do we
have any questions from our members
counselor passing them
um yeah you said that in the past
grain has been stored in other buildings
on the farm at the beginning and that um
there doesn't seem to be any increase in
the amount of grain that needs to be
stored is that correct
I can't really answer that one because
I'm not the applicant so I don't know
what their plans for the Landers in the
future but there are no buildings on the
land at present and all previous Farmers
that have found that land Contracting
have used the buildings that are on the
applicants other land at Cleve which
they say in their state in their
application that is just too difficult
to cut to because of the roads but it
has been used for the 15 years I've
lived in the village for so with the
applicant not being here did they come
to the Paris Council to discuss this
with you
no
uh Council of bird together
so in your present presentation you said
there is
an ultrasite on the farm where these
type of buildings could be cited do you
know why that wasn't explored by the
applicant I know you are not the
applicant of it the um the in the lvia
the there were five sites identified I
believe uh all of which were in the
vicinity of the proposed site which are
along the Ridgeline an escarpment of
above the village which has an amazing
Panorama going from it
it I can't understand why from a
practical point of view and from my own
professional experience why you would
build the buildings there as opposed to
close to the highway where there is
vehicular access and
um the ability to build a short track to
buildings where they're not seen from
the village
or most of the surrounding area other
than the bridal wing
and the public Highway
councilor scorer
thank you
um I noticed the same as you with the
straw building if you're going to build
a straw building that would be
completely
impractical but also as your
experiencing farming if you're going to
build a grain store you'd want a dryer
and cleaning facilities there as well I
am surprised well
it answered your question straight away
yes
um there's no utilities there there's no
water there's no electricity there's no
electricity in close proximity to the
buildings you would have to bring it by
overhead cable
from a fair distance I'm not going to
speculate on that distance but it is
fair distance away
I would expect some form of electricity
even if you were not having a drama I
would expect you to be able to have the
ability to put conditioning fans within
the grain to keep it in a salable state
which is the reason for them wanting the
bonds that being said
I also find it difficult to believe that
a grain store why would you Timber clad
at a grain store Grain Stores now need
to be dry Vermin proof to keep the grain
concrete panels and then it is in the
norm nowadays either to have insulated
metal clad sheets or metal sheeting not
Timber cladding it doesn't fit the
purpose
so what you're saying is that to store
grain you'd need electricity to cool it
down during during the winter yes so you
need to cool it straight after harvest
keep it conditioned until point of sale
and plus the fact if it was a wet
Harvest and you took the gradient wet
into the grain store
they have no ability to dry it therefore
they would have to cart it away from
site to take it to the dryer which they
already have in their buildings at Cleve
or they would have to sell it
at a deficit which is goes against their
economic purpose of doing these
buildings
thank you I think that uh very
thoroughly asked the question are there
any other questions from members
no in that case uh thank you very much
councilor Bing thank you thank you
apologies again about the name
okay uh so our next speaker is a Mr
David Burson on behalf of the applicant
Mr Burson you also have uh three minutes
I'll give you a 30 second warning
and uh when you're ready feel free to
start
I'm David Burson I'm here speaking on
behalf of the applicant as their
planning agent
your officers very well explained the
situation with the application the
planning consideration so I'm
principally here to answer questions
the applicant requires a grain store as
they purchase additional land in 2020 so
the buildings that they've used at
Cleve's Farm are no longer sufficient
the they are currently using most
buildings it's right that they have done
in the long term but the new land has
reached critical mass but it means it's
no longer practical or perhaps pull
another way they've reached a point
where it's worth building a building at
Cleve's farm for efficient farming sorry
Ashby Farm
the proposals before you tonight results
from long period of Engagement between
the applicants and the council including
pre-application discussions this has
involved an exhaustive search of sites
on the land which found the site on
which for Barnes are now proposed to be
the best site in landscape terms that's
led by a landscape assessment and the
application has a landscape and visual
impact assessment which confirms that to
be in the cat to be the case
to address a few of the points just
raised by the parish council
the ground stories of a conventional
construction with the ordinary concrete
walls and uh and insulation
the timber cladding is something which
has been recommended by the landscape
assessment and also by Council officers
it's an external treatment to make the
building suitable for the landscape the
straw Barn as well is secure at the
recommendation of the applicants
agricultural Consultants
the the land doesn't have any um house
on it it's not readily observed so for
security they've been advised but it's
wise to have an enclosed straw store
with regards to the landscape and visual
impact assessment and the capacity of
the trees nearby to screen the site
it should be stressful to know the Ia
has a very rigid methodology and this
includes a year-round assessment rather
than a best case scenario it considers
the impacts in worst case exposed
um Winters that sort of thing that's one
of the reasons the application took a
long time to prepare so that an
assessment could be undertaken in all
seasons
with regards to
utilities there aren't any there the
applicants would I'm sure rather have
avoid the expense of building a uh the
building where it wasn't have it close
to the road but again
they have looked to do rights by the
landscape which is
um this Arrangements
in summary your officers have confirmed
that the bonds are necessary for
agriculture and supported in principle
by the local plan they're also at the
correct design and form scale for the
farm holding the development will
support the rural economy and will also
assist just confirmed by the highways
officer in reducing Farm traffic on the
roads during Harvest we hope that you're
able to support this application and I'm
happy to answer questions
just bang on time thank you very much uh
members do we have any questions uh for
Mr person
so you have two questions so the first
one is is he is there going to be a
grain drying machine in there then is it
going to be a dry year in there and how
the electricity is produce for that and
um and also you know if any noise level
will be mitigated
um and then the other question is about
the routine plan
um how is that gonna work in
um in practice how is it going to be
implemented
because I know that you know the the
agvs are just gonna look at their Sat
Nav so I just want to know what how that
is going to be implemented by the
applicant thing
sure firstly on the grain dryer there's
not a grain dryer in the shed again the
the store is
size that's needed for the farm but it's
not of the size but we justify the
expense of a grain dryer the applicant
is going to manage that by through their
farming practices essentially
only harvesting the grain when it's uh
the the correct moisture content so that
it doesn't need to be dried in the store
and through the year it can be managed
by moving it in the in the building to
make sure it gets the air that's needed
in terms of obviously no dry no noise
things like that
in terms of a routing plan I believe
your office has consulted with the
highway Authority and concluded it's not
something that could be enforced through
condition but it's something which can
still be used by the applicant in terms
of
hgvs accessing the site don't do it on
an adult basis it's fine appointments
they'll be able to instruct them on the
best route into the site
fundamentally it's in the applicant's
interest to make their Journey to the
size as painless as possible and avoid
traffic on the um on the less suitable
roads so it will be self-managing to
large extent
any other questions nope in that case Mr
Burson I think that's everything thank
you very much
next speaker we have is our Ward member
councilor Wally hoggins
hi Council you have five minutes uh
again I'll give you a 30 second warning
when you're ready uh take it away
good evening new colleagues and those
who are already well acquainted with me
I'm here today as a district councilor
for brails and Compton and I am also the
representative of stratford-upon-avon
Council on the board of the Cotswold
National landscape whose purpose is to
protect all that makes the Cotswolds an
area of outstanding natural beauty for
future Generations a point of clarity is
that the applicants have only just
bought the land but have been farming
the land for some considerable time
without the need for an additional Barn
I provided you with a spectacular
pictures before you which clearly
demonstrate how outstanding the beauty
of this place is on the pictures before
you there are some with such shading
which clearly show you how visible these
proposed bonds will be you will clearly
see that there are no other buildings
visible along this Ridge line and that
it is because protecting the views and
Vistas from and to the comb are part of
the reason why any new developments on
ridgelines or escarpments must be
rejected the business and farming
reasons for the barns being cited here
are phenomenally and embarrassingly weak
and I am horrified that this proposal is
being recommended for approval if these
barns are approved I strongly suspect
that in 10 years time or thereabouts
there will be a planning application to
transform these wooden cladded barns
into a home it is clear from these
photographs why any would what anyone
would want a home here it is not clear
why an alleged farmer would want a barn
sighted here whilst long Compton Parish
Council and I acknowledge the principle
of development given by the agricultural
need of the applicant there are many
things that do not make this application
necessary or reasonable on this
particular site whilst we acknowledge
that there are other barns along this
escarpment they are all set into the
landscape not on the ridge the landscape
and visual impact assessment sets out
that the existing hedge line of mature
trees will shield the site from view but
as we all know trees are only in leaf
for a proportion of the uh the
assessment before you is therefore
flawed because it takes no account of
other potential sites for the barn on
the land which would have very limited
impact and would be of much greater
benefit to anyone serious about farming
and someone who is Credible and wanting
to reduce traffic movement and pollution
while there is a need for Grain Stores
to be of a certain height due to the
nature of tipping trailers a nominal
16-ton trailer will tip at full height
at 7.5 meters not 9.5 meters the size of
this store also outweighs a volume of
crop that can be reasonably be harvested
from the land this store could
potentially hold 900 to 1200 tons and
therefore is much larger than necessary
for the need of a holding it is
therefore obvious that if applicant were
to actually use these bands for
agricultural purposes rather than for
investment speculation that they would
be transporting large volumes of crops
onto the site therefore making a mockery
of any claims about reduced traffic
traffic movements to make the site
capable of taking hdv traffic a hard
service would need to be provided
pictures clearly show the current
unsuitable track this will undoubtedly
have a severe environmental impact to
the area without electric on site I
question how this will benefit the
storage of grain that will inevitably be
needed for drying or conditioning fans
to keep it in a salable condition these
facilities are already available at the
applicants buildings in Cleve in the
name Clement Harvester this will mean
all the grain harvested on this site
well in fact have to return to Cleve or
be sold at a deficit as drying costs
will be incurred the applicant states
that vehicle movements will be reduced
with the erection of the buildings but
without the installation of a track that
is appropriate for hgv movements in the
buildings which in the application says
there'll be no new vehicle access and
the site is only to be accessed by farm
machinery we fail to see how this will
be achieved we acknowledge that farm
trucks can be installed as a permitted
development subject to the appropriate
exemptions and lie license is being held
from the environment agency but query
why you would build a one kilometer
track from a roadside when you can build
a 130 meter track to a wholly more
appropriate and efficient site which is
close to the highway and which would
have a negligible impact on the comb to
conclude I remind this new panel of
counselors that you stood for election
in rural areas with a mandate to protect
rural areas and to prevent inappropriate
developments as did I this area must be
protected this is an inappropriate
development within the Cotswold area of
outstanding natural beauty and will
cause irreparable harm it is along
Compton community's wish that this
planning application for bonds is not
granted on this particular site of the
land owned by the applicant thank you
thank you very much councilor Wally
hoggins um 10 seconds within your time
so well done
um members do we have any questions for
our Ward member
yes yeah thank you councilor for that um
explanation
um I'm interested you've mentioned
other sites and there's a better site in
your view the applicant has come up with
a proposal that suggests that their
sighting is is the best and the least
harmful have you got a plan that you
could show us that where this these
other sites are that you consider are
more appropriate
you'd bring that map up of the site for
me thank you thank you and I'll be able
to pinpoint it for you from that thank
you thank you I just point out we do
have to consider the application in
front of us and and that is the one that
is cited you know it has set out in the
officers report
members will need to decide whether
what's in front of them is acceptable or
not and you don't need to consider any
other options if it's acceptable in the
landscape then you grant it if not then
you refuse it but you don't need to
consider other ones there's no
sequential test on this type of
development
counselor particular yes well um the
world member tell us about
um
how important the vistas are for the
community of Lancome and surrounding
rural Villages as well
so the the long Compton is in the Dark
Skies area of the Cotswold area of
outstanding natural beauty it is um it
is a fiercely protected area you have to
the um South and October north east and
west but you have got the most ancient
of monuments there which is the roll
right stones and you will clearly be
able to see you could this uh ban from
the roll right stones and and then and
enshrines in the Cotswold a OMB is that
it isn't just the fact that something is
if something can be seen from a point
which is a Vista and clearly those
photographs that we've seen this evening
show that the views that people have on
the walks you've seen on the plans that
there are footpaths there they shouldn't
be impeded that is what makes them areas
of outstanding natural beauty
um the the Ridgeline is is particular it
goes sort of from there all the way
along if you've got the brailles hills
then you've got it picks up again over
in um taiso
um
and down that way so it is that the
views from that are as important as
there and also you see on some of those
photographs there it is when you're in
the village looking up to that escarment
as well those are all sort of critical
importance to the the Cotswold aom it is
absolutely what makes that area very
very special indeed I am truly horrified
at the thought of this and the shading
on those photographs shows you the
impact that those that that development
would have on that side sorry
um we accepted the slides with the
shading on the Proviso that shading was
just indicating where it was not that it
was an accurate representation of its
scale i i i i i defer to what you're
just saying there thank you I'm sure you
all get the implications thank you thank
you councilor um councilor scorer next
thank you
you're the person on the ground in the
in the ward uh the applicant has just
bought the area or um do you know how
much uh how many acres that was
I don't know I know that the purchase is
a new is just just for clarification for
those of you not not farming you can
Farm an area
as I rent the fields or have the access
to it and then you can then buy it some
people just tenant Farmers through and
through so they just rent the fields but
the the acquisition these they've been
farming the fields for some time
I believe is that is that the question
is that the answer to your question
Council scorer I know just figuring out
the the tonnage of you you said 900 tons
I think 900 tons for the storage
uh no the the uh the storage far exceeds
the amount that this land can
um can um
grow I suppose thank you yeah that's why
I just wanted to know that yeah
okay I I think we we thought of that one
thank you very much Ruth um are there
any other questions for our Ward member
nope okay uh thank you very much
councilor Wally Hawkins
right uh so we're now moving on to a
points of clarification from our
officers does anyone have a question
counselor Adam I see first
chair um two if I may
so firstly
um
the images that councilor Whaley hoggins
just showed us with the blue on
would officers consider that as anything
other than just indicative of the
location is it representative of any
sort of scale or appearance because
there was a bit of contention there
that's the first question if you want to
answer that one first I'll ask the
second
uh as uh Richard
um kind of responded the views are
indicative but obviously the the shading
isn't representative of the scales of
the building
okay thank you and then the second
question also related to some of our
speakers
um I know that there are some conditions
on here about
um
the building should we be minded to
Grant uh should be used solely for
agriculture Etc does that in any way
mitigate somebody coming along with a
class Q application on a barn for
instance
could you repeat the question I didn't
quite catch the yeah sorry conclusion
um
the conditions say that the use of these
these barns should be solely
agricultural however obviously class Q
applications exist
would that condition mitigate any onward
class Q application in any way
um
I think without checking the class Q
rows I don't think you could because
they're built after the class queue
right if it was granted they would be
built after the class u q regs came in
and there's a caveat on that but like I
say I haven't checked that
so the odds are if
it's it's conjecture at the moment they
would have to come in for a full
planning application if they decided at
some point in the future that the
agriculture needed Fallen away and they
wanted to convert it but I would stress
that's conjecture at this stage and I
would re-emphasize the importance of
assessing the scheme as you see it
tonight
all right
um excuse me
um counselor Keithley
thank you chair
um we've heard from the counselor about
the landscape impact we've seen some
images
and I read in the the report that the
applicant had provided a landscape
impact as well concluding that they'd
chosen the best site
but unless I've missed it well I haven't
really seen I don't think is some images
from that assessment that the applicant
did
um that I could I could refer to when I
was looking at the images provided by
The Counselor have we got anything that
we could see
that demonstrates the the visual impact
of these barns on on The Ridges of this
precious area
yeah I've got that Beth you just bear
with me one second I'll just yeah thank
you that'd be very helpful no problem
so these are uh so there are 10 key
viewpoints that are within the lvia and
they're up on the screen now um I can
scroll through them
slowly if that suits
could I ask is there an image of the
proposed bonds overlaid a photo montage
overlaid anything like that there isn't
no
not from not as part of the application
it's not a requirement to okay
do you still want to run through them
or
yeah I think we can but you know um
clearly from from my perspective anyway
the important thing would be to see
um from as described a photo montage the
impact of these buildings on these views
and if the buildings aren't included in
this impact assessment I'm not sure
what I'm going to see from these
photographs
I think I think the best we could say
and there's a level of estimation here
is that those ash trees are probably
in the region of 14 to 18 meters high
The Proposal is probably in the region
of what was it nine
nine it's 9.5
so the proposal that would be seen from
there in winter
but it would be obviously below the
heights of the taller trees there
but it is only an estimate so you need
to give that
appropriate weight because we don't have
the photo mon charge and it's not
requirement to
uh right okay well thank you for that
clarification can I just say that I'm
I'm quite surprised
that in such a sensitive area
a photo montage which shows the the
scale and appearance we just keep it to
questions please thank you
Castle organ thank you chat
um the landscape and visual impact
assessment that
referred to
assessed five potential locations and
concluded that this one was the
preferred option and do you agree as
with the result of the assessment
foreign
yes um
obviously the land the lvia is
um submitted by the technical experts um
and obviously it's it's up to us to
assess that uh information that's
submitted uh and and we consider that
that was the uh Optimum sighting for the
buildings
Castle score
thank you chairman uh can I ask the
officer in his opinion are these
agricultural buildings fit for purpose
I would say all the evidence that we've
had from the applicant states that they
are they've given a clear intention as
to what they are you've heard tonight
from the applicants agent
um the circumstances around the
construction of those buildings and I
would say that that's a reasonable
argument that they've made and you
haven't had any other uh evidence on
that point what I would say is that on
some applications this Council will
consult an agricultural consultant
that's an option to members I wouldn't
recommend it but it's an option to you
if you are concerned about the uh the
construction and the use of the
buildings
sorry just to clarify that would entail
a deferral in order that we could take
that advice
any more questions for clarification
class of Fleming
just a quick one really I know she's
going through the consultations there's
been no response from the Cotswold
conservation board on either application
uh is that is that a surprise to you or
is that to you know based on what we've
heard tonight you'd have thought there'd
have been something come from them if if
that was the case
I'm just going to have a look at that
one counselor just to see if we have had
anything just to be sure and
okay um and I'll leave uh Stuart to feel
any further questions whilst I have a
look for that
are there any further questions
uh counselor passing him and the the
length of the the track seems
impractical to me you know what why
would you
uh why would the farmer want to have
built such a long track assumedly
there'll be a lot of construction going
into it
um and it would be far better closer to
the road from their point of view did
you did they they did they propose a
site so far away or is that because of
the impact assessment that the um
that position was such a long track is
needed
so the the five
um sites that were selected as part of
the lvia were all to the northern edge
of the field uh for thought process was
because of the the way the Topography of
the site and the way that the land
slopes down towards the North
that's part of the site was lower lying
hence what the the buildings were
proposed to be cited there that was the
thought process within the alphaia
it's like that so the impact of the
track the environmental and Landscape uh
are there other impacts of the track
that we're taking into consideration a
lot of land and so on I think the lvia
solely concentrates on the uh the
sighting of the buildings in terms of
the impact
um
the
the Cotswolds conservation board in fact
let's get the title right there is a the
Cotswold National landscape but they're
the Cotswolds conservation board they
provided a response and it's in effect
it's not giving as they say in their
words they don't provide a comprehensive
response they just flag up the policies
they require the local planning
Authority look to look at and those
policies are summed up in the report so
I'm content that we've taken into
account that representation by them but
they haven't given a view they haven't
objected they haven't supported they've
remain neutral
any other questions for officers in
which case we'll move into the debate
who would like to start
that's the score
thank you chairman
um I'm just I've got no issue I suppose
with agricultural buildings in the
countryside obviously it's a sustainable
business
um I'm just thinking that if I was to
build a grain store obviously the
applicants that they would harvest the
grain Optimum time when it's dry to
store it so they wouldn't have to cover
any drying costs generally what happens
if you if you're combining grain that
when it it comes off the field around
about 28 to 32 degrees you have to store
grain in between seven and six percent
so that's an awful lot of drop
to to store grain if you don't do that
obviously mites and termites get in so
from that point of view I don't think
it's a Sustainable Building for a fit
for purpose
um and if you are going to harvest it
when it's not so hot it's more likely to
have moisture and to store grain you've
got to have a moisture of 15 so not
having a facilities there to to dry and
cool it down you can chip it from their
other Farm but to dry it on the other
Farm but to store it to keep the
moisture the temperature down
I don't think it's it's uh the right
kind of building and also nine meters
high for a grain store when you've got
big tractors tipping up you know I I
don't think it's the the right kind of
building
okay thank you anyone else like to speak
on this
because
yeah
um I'm concerned about the height of
these agricultural buildings and and as
um councilor passingam was pointing out
the extensive truck to reach
these buildings
um and the is because I think
um as we heard from the war member we
got this distinctive landscape we got
the vistas that contribute to
um to the landscape itself we got
Tranquility as well
um so the the absence of noise pollution
and also of
visual clutter
so all these I'm just a bit concerned
about the location of these agricultural
buildings and their size in my
experience as the world as a world
member of a rural area
um The Grain Stores were accompanied by
grain drying systems as well which
obviously brings noise as well this is
this is not available here but
um I don't know so I'm not
um at the moment I go quite a lot of
concerns about this
thank you chairman
um my view is that I've got some
um grave concerns given the
um importance of this particular
landscape area that I am not convinced
about the visual impact and the
buildings of the
um on on the landscape and the ridge
line and the applicant doesn't seem to
have whilst they provided an assessment
I I feel that the applicant hasn't
provided proper clarification and
Clarity in that respect
uh I'd like to get some guidance from
our planning manager just on what
further advice or investigations could
be carried out to satisfy some of the
concerns that have been raised uh rigid
are you able to elaborate please
if if members choose to refuse this and
a reason is lack of agricultural need or
lack of agricultural suitability it
would be advisable to defer the
application to allow us to seek the
views of an agricultural consultant
who's qualified to comment on what's
been submitted and then we would bring
it back to committee
if however
that doesn't form a reason for refusal
of this application it can be determined
tonight
right uh
perhaps I just see a couple of puzzle
faces
it's not for me to put words into
members mouth but let's say for example
members are concerned about the
landscape and the impact on the
landscape and that was a refusal and
that was the only refusal there would be
no need to defer because the
agricultural case would have been
accepted
the
the impression I'm getting from the
comments made so far are based around
the agricultural use of the the land and
how that relates to the applications
directly not necessarily the landscape
impact is that broadly
in line with your what you've said in
which case would we be looking to defer
or
are we going to make a decision tonight
on on the basis that you get with the
information that we have
slur score
thank you chairman I I would be happy to
defer
um only because I don't think it's uh
the their fit for purpose but as a
sustainable uh business I'm happy that
you know that they've purchased an extra
200 acres and they're looking for an
extra 900 storage tons which is around
about four four tons of the acre which
that land would probably grow but I
still think they they're not fit for
purpose though so
um so I would maybe defer it to
an agricultural um uh specialist for
the council
for a bit more clarification
okay thank you is that a proposal to
differ
councilor Eden please
um sorry I I partly disagree with you
councilor Adam in as much as I am
concerned about the impact on the
Ridgeline and and that
how that how we don't have a clear
representation of that is that something
that we can ask for as part of the same
deferral should we
choose to go down that route are we
allowed to ask for clarity
further clarity yes you can in short you
you could defer to say firstly you want
independent agricultural advice and
secondly you would like the applicant to
draw up
um some photo montages that actually
reflect the dimensions of the building
from
um
when seen in the landscape and I think
you would probably want to leave it to
them to decide which views to look at
unless there's a specific view you want
to see in which case I would set that
out
okay I'll come to council to put
together next but um first I've just got
to clarify Council scorer could you make
your proposal again please just make
sure your microphone's on
can you hear me uh yeah and make sure
it's also for both applications yes yeah
um I'd just like to defer the
application for agricultural Specialists
to make sure that the the buildings are
fit for purpose thank you very much
councilman together
um for me it's also the landscape so as
we cancel already then is the
distinctive landscape the impact on the
landscape on the Ridgeway the natural
beauty the intrinsic natural beauty of
the Cotswolds landscape which is you
know linked to tranquility and so on so
for me it's both really
see
okay thank you councilor Adam
um would councilor score be open to a
friendly amendment to his proposal and
and to also include the visual impact
drawings as well as part of his proposal
if so I would gladly second that
I guess
lovely thank you
um
we've got a proposal to defer and a
second I think from from my part in this
I'd just to come back on Council Adams
points I think I understand the concerns
that have been raised in terms of
landscape given the setting and the
sensitivity they're in that have been
raised by the war member in the parish
council
that being said that they have put
forward an application that that has has
looked at some of these aspects I think
if we're going to defer including that
would be a worthwhile
way to put it to bed along with the
agricultural question on that basis I'm
happy to support that is there anyone
else who would like to speak
on this item counselor Fleming
a quick just a quick one really
um I worked in Grain handling machinery
for 30 years none of the problems that
have been talked about about this grain
are insurmountable there are mobile
drives you can bring to site
there are radio stacking conveyors where
you can stack this stuff as high as you
like I don't really see that the
building Being Fit for purpose is a real
it would really stick once you get your
agricultural expert in but I think
that's the way to go get get a
professional to tell you what's going on
no I appreciate that view and I think
the point is that none of us here are
able to have a professional view on the
agricultural benefits of of these
buildings
um so I'd be happy to sort of defer on
that basis if there are no further
members wishing to speak
um we'll be looking to defer to gain
that do we need anything else with the
officers on that basis
no okay
and just for clarity
um customer score and Council Legend
you're both happy that those deferrals
are for both separate applications
correct
yeah yes chair thank you very much in
that case
um
I'd like to ask for all those in favor
of deferral of both applications
we're gonna have to do these separately
but that's okay so can I have all those
in favor of deferring application
22-01485 ful
okay that's unanimous and that passes
and then can I have all those in favor
of deferring application 22 Dash slash
zero one four eight six slash ful
okay in which case uh this Council
resolves to defer both applications
uh at the land north of Oakham Road
Southwest of long Compton
all right
thank you very much everyone on that one
in which case we can move on to our
final application item number seven
application
2300337 ful Tamworth in Arden Village
Hall vicarage Hill uh the presenting
officer is Emma Booker
as soon as she's able to sit down and
get things lined up you can take it away
thank you I'm here to present an
application for a flagpole
um in the village of Tamworth and Arden
you can see on the map in front of you
that we're at the north of the district
um and the site is roughly located where
the black dot is
here is a map that denotes the
conservation area boundary the
application site is in the center of the
screen in the red line boundary
so it's the Village Hall we're in the
center of the conservation area and
we're in close proximity to several
listed buildings the list of buildings
are those properties that are in red
this is the site plan the development is
located where the pink dot is so it's in
the bottom right hand corner of the site
um and you can see those list of
buildings Ivy Cottage Abbeville Etc on
the right hand side of the screen
this is the proposed development
um obviously not with that backdrop but
you can see what we are proposing
so this is a picture of the application
site it would be erected you see where
the telephone pole is
to the to the right hand side of that on
that elevated land within the grounds of
the Village Hall
this is I've just moved in a different
aspect now so the listed Cottages are on
the right hand side
and then those are those listed they're
listed as a group
um
and that's it that's all I have to show
you so thank you
thank you very much now we have no
registered registered speakers on this
item and so it is an option for
committee to delegate this to officers
um
otherwise if and
if members are interested otherwise will
be points of clarification from the
officer
foreign
for 21 days a year is that just an
arboretary number or is there a reason
for that
so the concern is to do with the the
noise that's generated by the flapping
of the flag because it's so close to
Residential Properties the 21 days
um it was felt it would cover the days
of the year where the applicants would
want to
fly the flag say I think it it you know
it was suggested it needed to be
controlled so that it wasn't a nuisance
60 365 days of being
Casa Fleming
if you're not propose that we delegate
to officers
thank you very much councilor Eden I
will second that thank you excellent
Madness uh looks like we have a proposal
and a second up for delegating to
officers
can I see all those in favor
unanimous
in which case that's our final item
um is there any urgent business
no urgent business in which case
um that ends the main agenda and I
declare the meeting closed